So let's see if we can correctly use MSYNC.
Let's say that we have a processor with a
very relaxed consistency model where all four reorderings are
allowed. Including reodering writes to different locations on a core.
Let's say that this is the code we are
executing. We do a load link of lock into R1.
We then do a branch if we didn't get
the lock, back to checking, we do a store conditional
trying to now get the lock. We look back, if we didn't get the lock then we
load the variable incremented and store it. Then we free the lock by writing
zero to it. So the question for you is where do we need MSYNC if anywhere here?
Do we need one here? Do we need on here? Do we need on
here? Here? Here? How bout here? How bout here?
How bout here? And how bout at the end of everything?